[Music]
allen is with us alan is in new jersey
newark to be precise hi alan how are you
how you doing ramsay um just trying to
put this all together and i hope to see
how we can best unpack this
now i have about
me and my wife of about like 900 000 in
debt but it's not
all crazy that is investment debt so
just uh give you a run about um just
from what we make
uh my wife she's works at uh the port
she's a long showman and she makes about
160.
i work in the i.t field and uh the peter
field and i make about 115 so let's put
that there
i have a nice little nest egg of about
60 grand
that's put aside and i'm 33 she's 32
we're married with four kids that's
under 10. so who is 10 another yeah so
that's one thing
um about the debt portion
i have about
166 000 in my primary home
i bought a house that i renovated
and
you know i just renovated it as a
two-family home
and that's probably arv it's probably
worth about 400 right now i don't have
no debt on that but however
i had to take it out about a hundred
thousand to put into the property to
renovate it right so so you do have debt
on it or you don't i don't have that
with that property no i don't have that
on it but but you got a hundred thousand
unsecured
unsecured that you used on that property
okay correct i got 20
well it's less than 100 but it's like 20
in the line of credit yeah and about you
know 50 like about 50 from your favorite
place so far so
yeah i got i got that one and then we
bought another house a four family for
about four
for half a million but we got it down to
like 450 we put some money into it we
put about 40 into it what's it worth
today it's probably 6.50 and what do you
owe on that
[Music]
okay there it is all right
and then
we have about
uh my wife's got a car
23 000 in car and about 6 000 on credit
cards no student loans we paid all that
off
and
yeah okay
why are you calling us how can we help
um now here's the thing the my
the property that doesn't have any debt
on it right
i need to pull money off that property
to get rid of the interest rate on
the debt that i took out the roof to the
renovated right yeah why are you calling
us
to see what do you want to do
how could you what's the best way to
structure it and to see what your
recommendation is
okay
um
i started buying real estate when i was
22 by the time i was 26 i owned 4
million worth and i had a
about a 3 million debt on it
so i had a million dollars worth of
equity in the real estate starting from
nothing
um
what you're doing sounds very stressful
to me it does not sound like there's any
peace in your voice
yeah we try to figure it out we try to
structure everything so yeah i think you
i think you play the edges on everything
don't you
uh no not really you know yeah
my choice i guess every time holder has
170 000 miles when i never went to a
dealership to buy a car
you moved the p three or four times on
the shell still trying to hide it just
in this conversation
yeah you're man um
we're not in the debt restructuring
business we're in the debt payoff
business and it doesn't sound like
you're at a point where you want to
become completely debt free or that
you're willing to do what it takes to
get there yeah the the question you're
asking out and the the answers we're
going to give
are all around the same issue the issue
is okay you're 33 when you're 43 what
moves are going to make you the best off
okay the best off financially and have
the best quality of life with four
little kids and both of you working big
high-stress jobs
and everything so
i'm going to get rid of one of these
properties and a whole bunch of not if
not all of this debt in the process
because i think that's going to add an
amazing amount of peace to your life a
you cut your
uh number of tenants in half
b you got rid of almost if not all of
your debt so 400 and 166 pays off
the hunt you get rid of everything but
the debt on the rental your you pay off
your mortgage your car your credit cards
and the hundred thousand it's owed you
sell the 400 000 property that's
probably what i'm gonna do because that
will take me because the peace
and the calm steady movement rather than
the flailing about will cause you to
build more wealth over time
and you you've been you've been just
kind of pushing the edges on this maybe
you don't realize you are but it uh and
if you don't realize you are that's even
more of a problem because i i know this
guy because i was him i mean i i they
something about the real estate business
they take the risk meter out of your
heart and they put it on table and hit
it with a hammer and break it so you no
longer can measure risk and you don't
you don't perceive that all of this is
risk you just see returns you go
well the renters are paying it off no
they're not the renters don't pay their
bill half the time you got a problem all
the time with that
and so
it's just an issue so no i um
you know i'm going to move you backward
what feels like backward to you but sets
you into a real calm place
let's visit where you are at that point
okay the probably the 650 with the 450
loan is cash flowing
it's probably cash flowing a little not
a lot
but you got zero debt then no house
payment
no car payment no hundred thousand
dollar unsecured hanging out there at a
high interest rate
and you only got a couple tenants
and you make 275 000 a year and you're
33 years old that's a much better place
than where you are today brother
to be that's a much more solid platform
to launch into the future
we don't find
alan very many people in our millionaire
study that borrowed their way into
becoming millionaires using the system
you're using or that i used when i went
broke
most people the vast majority of
millionaires do not do that to become
millionaires and so
that data is real
it's not a theory and it's not a well
what about the
[Music]
there's no arguing with the actual data
most people dave especially young guys
they want to get into real estate
investing and our advice is to have a
paid for property for yourself first
then do all of your real estate
investing in cash
to them it sounds insane
why do we say that
because
the shortest distance to wealth is
always
no debt
it's the shortest fastest route
and it's not just i made that up i mean
it's in the bible the borrower's slave
to the lender oh also
all the data with the ten thousand
millionaires that we've studied oh also
if you just walk around and talk to rich
people they're not going to tell you you
know i did it with bitcoin
you know i did i got this big hit i
bought llamas
i opened a llama farm they were big one
time there was a big rich quick thing on
llama llama farms wow and i bought
beanie babies they don't tell you that
and they don't say i did nothing down
real estate because i got to tell you
man
i knew probably
100 people doing nothing down real
estate in the 80s
100 of them are out of the business wow
or
they paid off everything and got out of
the debt business one of the two i
actually know one guy that he cashed out
of about three quarters of his portfolio
ended up with 25 as many properties
and they were all debt-free
he got everything he got tired of he got
tired of living on the edge most people
go well that's stupid dave you're losing
out on all the cash flow of the
properties well the thing is in the in
when they're leveraged they don't cash
flow that much
you know that 450 over 650 he's not
making much money their margins on that
after you have after you have vacancy uh
you have loss
you know credit loss meaning they don't
pay the bill they go into bankruptcy you
have a heat and air unit go out you have
a roof leak
um you know you pay your taxes
you pay you know and by the time you
finish all that he's not making much
cash flow on that
he's not getting rich off that house now
the value may be shooting up but the
actual cash on cash there's not much
there
so this idea that somehow you're going
to like
just buy a house and the money just
starts coming in no it really doesn't if
you leverage it up to your eyeballs so
it's all about delayed gratification
yeah it's go a little slower or go a lot
slower which in the end of the story
ends up being faster he who hastens to
be rich will not go unpunished there it
is again